ich fürchte es geht um schuldzuweisungen
oder um die frage wer trägt für was die
verantwortung und das ist genau das was
jetzt nicht diskutiert werden sollte
die menschen erwarten jetzt lösungen wir
müssen uns jeden tag vor augen halten
dass es in dieser zeit menschen gibt die
vor dem wirtschaftlichen abgrund stehen
die nicht wissen wie es weiter geht die
existenzängste haben und die erwarten zu
recht von der politik eine beantwortung
der frage wann steht wie viel impfstoff
zur verfügung
in welcher reihenfolge wird geimpft wann
sind wir dran das ist das was jetzt von
der politik an antworten erwartet werden
herr bosbach braucht man dafür wirklich
ein impfgipfel ich meine wir sprechen ja
seit vier wochen darüber und was die
menschen bis jetzt nicht verstanden
haben ist vor allem die frage warum so
wenig impfstoff da ist oder ich
eigentlich hätte es nur eine devise
geben dürfen nämlich so schnell
impfstoff so schnell wie möglich und so
viel impfstoff wie möglich vielleicht
hat der eine oder andere gedacht wir
müssen lange verhandeln
das sind dann auch den preis mag sein
aber doch bitte nicht in diesen zeiten
nichts ist teurer als den lockdown immer
noch länger aufrechtzuerhalten mit einem
enormen volkswirtschaftlichen verlust
das ist ja nicht nur der verlust der
betroffenen unternehmer das ist ja auch
der verlust an steuereinnahmen die der
staat hat oder steigenden sozialkosten
und ich glaube niemand hätte doch der eu
oder der bundesrepublik der regierung
einen vorwurf gemacht wenn man mehr
impfstoff gekauft hätte als man am ende
tatsächlich benötigt hat wenn wir zu
viel gehabt hätten dann wäre die
weltweite nachfrage nach diesen
impfstoffen sofort dagewesen andere
rinder pachten ja genau wie wir jetzt in
dort schon wir sehen ja in israel ihr
sehen es in den usa wir sehen es in
großbritannien dass dort die impfquote
wesentlich höher ist als bei uns
herr bosbach und gleichzeitig hören wir
jetzt aus dieser internen sitzung geben
dass dort die beiden kommissare einmal
für beschaffung und dann für gesundheit
dort sitzt
uns sagen na ja wir sehen eigentlich
keine schuld bei der eu wir haben so
bestellt wie geplant hat
da haben da einige eu-politiker den
bezug zu den menschen den bezug auf zur
realität verloren
jedenfalls den bezug dazu was die
menschen in diesen tagen fühle was sie
spüren nämlich es gibt doch auch einen
vertrauensverlust in die politik
es ist jeder der beteiligt war darauf
bedacht dass er auf keinen fall
irgendeine verantwortung oder gar schuld
trägt dass man ihm jedenfalls keinen
vorwurf machen kann so wandert der
schwarze peter
nicht nur durch die republik sondern
durch ganz europa ich glaube es wäre
vertrauensbildend wenn die europäische
kommission sagen würde mit ihre
kenntnisse von heute hätten wir
schneller verhandelt hätten wir
möglicherweise auch früher höhere mengen
bekommen können war warum ist das so
schritten das zuzugeben wenn uns andere
länder doch zeigen wie es geht viel
glauben nur keinen fehler zugeben das
schadet mir oder meiner politischen
reputation
ich glaube dass es vertrauen stärken
wäre wenn einmal verantwortliche auch
fehler und versorgen müsse eingestehen
würde mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bet schaut euch hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren